i watch the oscars because it lets me
see the human beings behind these
fantastical experiences it celebrates
the inner child and the dreams of so
many since i was about seven or eight
years old i started going to the movies
with my dad growing up as a kid it was
always a dream of mine i grew up with
the oscars always dreamed about sort of
being part of this creative community
remember
that you are part of a legacy that
you're part of a world of filmmakers
it's celebrating
my community it's just a very communal
experience i guess with the rest of the
world i'm in awe
of all these
extraordinary people whether it's in
front of the camera behind the camera i
like seeing the joys of people's names
being called alfonso
ronnie malek
lupita nyong'o
i love to see the best day of someone's
life
and that's sometimes what you see
understanding that there are just people
glamorous and ethereal as they are but
they are just other people like me is
hugely empowering and encouraging it's a
bit like that movie cinema paradiso you
know about nostalgia italy for cinema
going to the movies and what it
represents family or friends and
bringing people together and then of
course my experience working in this
industry kind of like opening the back
door and getting to look inside and see
what really goes on making something out
of nothing it's it's magic
and i think that gives hope to millions
of potential filmmakers around the world
it's wonderful to share those dreams
[Music]